there's a myth that teenagers don't care
about privacy assumed in this myth is
that teenagers are participating in all
of these online public places like
social media and they're giving up their
right to be to be private what you find
is that young people care deeply about
privacy they want to participate in
public spaces they want to be a part of
public life but they want to be in a
public is different than the notion that
they want to be public their choice to
participate in public spaces is very
much distinct from their decision to
care about what they share don't share
one of the most important things to
realize is that social media social
network sites like Facebook MySpace
Twitter etc are in many ways a form of
networked public they're a place where
people come to share to socialize to
engage with their friends and there are
public spaces in the in the sort of
canonical sense the harbor Massey and
sense the political sense but also in
the social sense there is space that's
constructed through network technologies
and they're an imagined community of
people that come together in a networked
space this is the fundamental notion of
a networked public and it is the
networked publics that young people are
participating in when they had joined
social media sites like Facebook so many
things are very different about the
kinds of social media sites that we see
fact is that they're the content you
participate in is persistent it sticks
around for a long time it's searchable
you can copy and paste things from one
place to another and scales at much
greater rates than ever before but one
of the things that's really radically
different about this has to do with a
fundamental idea of what it means to
share in a face-to-face setting when
we're sitting and having a conversation
our interactions are private private by
default public through effort we talk we
socialize we joke around and those
interactions actually maintain between
the two of us unless one of us decides
to share them that process of sharing is
a process of publicity and at that
moment of publicity we share widely but
the thing is is you have to make a
conscious effort to share it becomes a
moment where you want to decide what is
important to get out there and to act
and make it public online things are
radically different in fact it flips the
other way our interactions and so
from meadia end up being public by
default and then private through effort
so you share and the sharing is
fundamentally makes it visible to a lot
of different people but if you want to
actually constrain it you go and you go
out of your way to make it private and
so what happens is that young people
when they're participating in social
media they share all sorts of things
that they just don't particularly care
about just like in physical spaces we
would keep private things that we don't
particularly care about the result of
which is that what happens online feels
like it's really much more public
because so much more is visible than
ever before now young people in many
ways are aware of the radical
differences because of social media
and they're trying to make sense of it
they're trying to make sense of what it
means in their lives let me tell you a
little bit about Alicia she noted that I
just think that technology is redefining
what's acceptable for people to put out
about themselves I've grown up with
technology so I don't know how it was
before this boom of social networking
but it just seems like instead of
spending all of our time talking to
other individual people and sharing
things that would seem private we spend
all of our time putting it out in one
module of communication where people can
go and access it if they want to so it's
just more convenient I think that adults
think this is about privacy because they
see pictures we put about things that we
never had that ability so when they see
our photo albums when they see
conversations on our Facebook wall to
wall they think it's a huge breach of
privacy and your personal ideas or
whatever
now what Alicia is really pointing out
is that there's this shift going on and
that shift has to do with the way in
which things become much more public
just by their very default now in order
to cope with this young people develop
all sorts of strategies to really
maintain privacy to find a way to really
think through what privacy actually
looks like in an online space and they
find strategies that work for them
strive strategies that allow them to
feel like they have some sort of power
it's important to realise that
fundamentally the way that they think
about privacy requires two core issues
one their ability to control a social
situation to understand the situation to
control how information flows in there
and to make sense of it but the second
part is that they're also demand that
they have agency in that space they have
the ability to assert that control over
the space and when they lack that they
really struggle it's through those sort
of moments that you actually see what
goes on and how they
privacy let me tell you a little bit
about hunter hunter is a
fourteen-year-old geeky boy living in
Washington DC that I had the great
opportunity to meet and you know as a
young black man living in a community he
struggles with different kinds of
challenges one of them is the fact that
his environment at home where he hangs
out with his family and his cousins and
his friends at home is a very different
environment than what he experiences
when he goes to school he's in a magnet
school where very much is driven by
education is driven by learning and at
home the values are very different and
so one of the things is is he's trying
to deal with different worlds all the
time he's trying to deal with what ends
up being a context collapse and so he
said when I'm talking to my friends on
Facebook or I put up a status something
I hate is when people that I'm not
addressing in my statuses comment on
them in my old school people used to
always call me nerdy and then I was the
least black black person that they've
ever met some people say that I said on
Facebook should I take offense to the
fact that somebody put a ringtone white
and nerdy as for me and it was a joke
and I guess we were talking about it in
school and my sister comes out of
nowhere and goes aw baby bro and I'm
like no don't say that I wasn't talking
to you
and one hunters highlighting there is
that he's really struggling to have this
moment where he wants to make Facebook
and his conversations there with his
friends who understands the jokes and
the kind of laughter that goes on and he
doesn't want to deal with the sort of
collisions of these different kind of
social contexts so I asked him you know
how did how do you actually know who's
being talked to on Facebook status
updates and they respond he's like well
I guess that's the point
sometimes it's probably hard but I think
it's just a certain way that you talk I
will talk to my sister a different way
than I talk to my friends at school or
for my friends at my old school and I
might say well I fell asleep
um in this case class by accident and
they'll say oh yeah miss Kay is so
boring and she's like oh well you know
and my sister will respond and say oh
well you shouldn't fall asleep you
should pay attention and I mean they
think you should fear to figure out that
I'm not talking to you if I'm talking
about a certain teacher and 100 is
really trying to achieve with this is
he's trying to assert a sense of what
the social norms are he's trying to say
this is how you're supposed to know
you're supposed to read the context
you're so
to behave accordingly and it really
struggles because he doesn't have this
comfortable way of dealing with it now
this comes up for Hunter all the time
and so one of the things he started
developing was using technical
strategies as a means to actually cope
with this and this came up when he was
talking about the fact that his friends
very much liked playing sort of geeky
games they were really into legends of
Zelda they were really into Pokemon but
at home in his community at home it was
all about shooter videos and then I
heard video games and the idea that he
would possibly play Pokemon was really
unacceptable and so he found that he
would start writing about Pokemon start
writing about legends of Zelda and
purposefully block his cousins and his
family members from seeing those posts
and in blocking it he was not trying to
say that they couldn't get access to
this aspect of his life but that they
didn't seem to understand the rules
about when commenting was appropriate so
by blocking them he kept them out as a
way of managing a certain type of social
norms a way of guaranteeing a certain
kind of social politeness that he
couldn't get through any other means now
there are other technical strategies and
many of the technical strategies that we
found in our research really focus on
pretty extreme moves by young people to
try to cope with things one of them I
think it's really interesting comes from
a young woman named Shamika and she
challenges she's challenged on Facebook
because she's always having to deal with
social dramas and she finds that people
go back into her past look at all of his
old material and Drudge it up to be a
part of the contemporary environment and
she doesn't want to deal with all the
past being a part of things so what she
decides to do is that every day when she
logs into Facebook she goes and she
deletes every comment that anybody left
for her after she read it and then she
goes and she leaves comments on other
peoples pages and the next day she goes
and she deletes those and she keeps her
Facebook wall effectively white and it's
a way for her of actually letting the
past disappear so I asked her I said
well anybody could copy and paste this
content to anybody could take it and
save it and she's like yes but that
would be really creepy and weird and the
idea that people would do that would be
such a violation that it would be a
rupture in a different level so by
removing this content she could sort of
minimize her dramas know an interesting
layout her friend actually took a
different approach to all of this this
was mckaela mckaela was really
struggling with the fact that in her
physical environment people kept looking
at her content and taking it out of
context as well what she decided to do
is that every day when she would log
into Facebook she would deactivate her
account she would make her account so
that it was rendered basically invisible
nobody would be able to search for her
nobody able to find her nobody could
leave comments nobody could send her
messages
she basically looked like she did not
have an account on Facebook and then
every day when she would log in she
would reactivate it and she joked around
saying that the adults who were looking
for her tended to actually look at it
during the day when her account was
unactivated and nobody actually bothered
but her friends to talk to her at night
when she had reactivated her account it
was a way of turning Facebook into being
a real-time activity and all of these
sort of technical strategies extreme
technical strategies a way of really
modifying the technology to achieve the
social goals that young people are
trying to get at especially with regard
to privacy now for all those technical
strategies they only go so far and one
of the more interesting things is when
young people actually start to develop
more social strategies strategies that
allow them to maintain some sense of
social sensibility by basically
separating who can understand what's
going on one of the examples that I most
loved from this work comes from a young
woman named Carmen and she talks a lot
about how her mother tends to comment on
all these different things she writes
online and she's always like go away but
she doesn't want to delete the comments
that her mother leaves for her because
she doesn't want her mother to feel bad
her mother is a partner for Facebook
world and that's very important to her
but she's frustrated that her mother
doesn't seem to understand the social
boundaries and so when her mother
comments one of the problems is that
that makes all of her friends disappear
they don't comment after that and she's
constantly trying to navigate those
worlds so one day she was sort of having
a really bad day she had broken up with
her boyfriend and she was trying to find
a way to signal to her friends that she
was not doing so well it was a really
difficult time for her but she didn't
she knew if she wrote anything sort of
emotionally sappy her mother would flip
out her mother would overreact and so
she decided to take his different
strategy and she put up song lyrics
because song works are very important
for young people she put up song lyrics
that expressed her emotions in a way
that only her friends would understand
and she put up song lyrics from the song
always look on the bright side of life
now the best thing about this song is
that
in a Monty Python skit which she and her
friends immediately knew and they
recognized it but it's not it sounds
really happy right always look on the
bright side of life and yet it's sung
during the part of the film when the key
character and the life of Brian is about
to be executed right and so her friends
immediately recognize that there were
multiple layers to this her mother on
the other hand wrote a nice comment say
it looks like you're doing really well
and her friends called her right and
this is a way in which she sort of
maintained a sort of sense of social
privacy in this environment because she
was able to send a message to her core
friends while still hiding it from other
people in many ways you can think of
this as a form of social steganography
it's about hiding in plain sight it's
taking a core message and making it
available to only to those who are
really in the know and only those who
even know how to look for the message
it's this act of actually hiding
information or making things only
visible to certain people that is
extremely important and a lot of young
people find strategies that allow them
to do this what you see is that what
they're doing is that they're trying to
actually make it so that the content
itself is accessible but the meaning is
only interpretable to those that are in
the know now sometimes there's a sort of
act of performativity that comes with it
of letting people know that they don't
know what's being said and we've
constantly found this in our fieldwork
as well this is an example from North
Carolina we're sitting with a young
woman and she was showing me her face
book and on it there's this message that
says I'm sick and tired of all of this
and it was liked by 32 people and said
by one of her friends and further in the
feed there was another one who says
she's such a [ __ ] and it was like 450
people I was like what is this what does
this is all about and Sarina satin told
me all sorts of different things about
the drama's of our school and how these
two girls were fighting and what it was
about and all of the details but none of
this is rendered visible in these two
messages and yet everybody in the friend
group knew exactly what was going on
they knew exactly what it referred to
and they know exactly what she referred
to it was a way of using pronouns to
actually hide information so that
teachers and parents had no clue what
was going on
and likewise the friends outside of the
area didn't really know the meaning but
everybody who was in the know fully got
it here is an example of the ways in
which you can actually give full
access to the content without actually
giving any access to the meaning
teenagers are regularly trying to engage
in public spaces there regularly trying
to find ways to convey meaning to convey
was important to them but they're not
doing it just so publicly as we may
think their content may be public but
the meaning is often not and even when
they're content this public is only a
fraction of what is actually rendered
visible amongst their friend group
there's a lot of ways in which privacy
actually is in the interstitial spaces
of these online environments and one of
the most important things to realize is
the way in which as young people engage
with these public spaces they continue
to hold on to privacy and find new ways
of enacting it thank you